everything is science so there's not
anything that you even touch or see or
do that has nothing to do with science
[Music]
the fascinating thing that I've always
found about physics is it studies
collections of objects and what they do
together and you think that there has
nothing to do with people other than
that people are studying it but people
are like particles people get together
on a road they form traffic jams which
is like something solidifying emergence
is to me one of the most exciting things
that we can study in science example
when you look up in the sky and you see
these intricate patterns that birds form
when they're when they're flying around
those patterns are nothing that you
would have guessed at mathematics is
actually a vehicle for helping people
flourish so if you think about what it
what it means to do mathematics you know
part of what you're trying to do in
mathematics is seek truth and in seeking
truth you build in abilities virtues of
rigorous thinking handling ideas well
being intellectually honest
[Music]
you
[Music]